good morning everyone and thank you for
joining us today
so for the first time ever been doing
this for a few weeks now only amess
which is one of the panelists is on a
bit of some technical issues so do bear
with and he should join us shortly but
look firstly thank you all for joining
us just a bit of a bit of housekeeping
so all of you know how you can get
involved and engaged with us and the
panelists so all you should be just
coming in now in a sec actually so first
things first as Sam's message Afghans
message you guys can can chat in there
and talk in there and in the public chat
and then the other thing to keep an eye
on and to use is to the right of you at
the top as well you'll see Q&A so you'll
see that I put in there ask your
questions here and at any point when
we're talking when we're discussing
things feel free to submit your
questions and what you'll also be able
to do is click up vote on the questions
that you want to be are asked and I'll
make sure they get answered so let's
just start with some introductions guys
and hopefully you'll join us bless em
but we on the left out of you if you
could let everyone know who you are what
you do and then chose we'll go to you
yeah thank you hello everyone public
sending a message it's interesting to
see somebody I'm from Tokyo you said
that's it yeah another Sam I'm thinking
that's super cool and all he's gonna
join us from London but he can't join
for the intro hm so we're finding James
and I am a billing manager so I manage a
team of three four including myself at
the moment um Phinney james as a
business place sales and marketing
professionals in
G sector across the UK amia and the US
so we've got an all-clear in the UK and
Manchester is our headquarters and we've
got some people in the ground over in
San Francisco in New York so that's
probably what we do perfect
and Charles gets on on Charles I work
for Austin freighter I've been in
recruitment now for just just under
seven years so just welcoming to my
LinkedIn is six years and eight months
to be precise and that has gone light as
you can imagine super super quick but so
I started at the bottom from training E
and then now up to a point where I'm a
contract manager watching Frazer for my
two knees we're a team of six in total
so I manage five we're a contract team
obviously within the tech space
primarily at the moment based out of red
in with a view to kind of be landing
more permanently in London at some point
in cool Thank You Charles and then only
look we can we can see you there's a
40-plus people with us right now just to
let you know but can can you hear as Iko
lee I think I can hear can you hear me
at all yeah yeah all good so if you if
you could just do a quick intro Ollie to
let everyone know sort of who you are
people that you manage and if you're a
plan contract recruits and then we'll
get going yeah anyway so poem recruiter
cross marketing a ditch saw everything
in terms of financial services world and
convenience the FinTech space not that
kind of stuff but in recruitment about
seven years being a three searched for
last five of those coming up my five
year anniversary there and joined the
business pretty small and then kind of
help them grow that business out now
manage a team of six people and all in
London book recruiting kind of
nationally in then a little bit more in
the states as well but yes yeah that's
perfect and amazing and as I said only
don't if you if you crush on Finn don't
stress like just come back and we'll
we'll do a bit alright so what I'd like
to start with guys just just to set this
for everyone is how have you found
things over the last couple of weeks
Charles only start of you how have you
found things mate what's been going on
in your world well I think
rapidly-changing is probably I would sum
it up so we like we're fortunate like as
a business our CEO and the board kind of
made us all effectively mobile anyway so
that we had the kind of infrastructure
in place that anyone could work anywhere
so I guess the only thing was like when
when this all kind of kicked off was
like okay well how are we going to
perform with everyone working remote and
what you know the stress test is spent
stress tests on the systems and we
thought that and that's all to see
worldwide because we've got offices in
Germany as well as America I think like
maybe to start with we probably we knew
that this was what was he gonna be a big
thing but I think realistically has just
been ever-evolving changing and I think
we're just having to adapt as we go okay
there's an acceptance piece that maybe
where we don't have all the answers so
and that's okay
but we're all in this together kind of
mentality I think is probably where
we're at right now well love that mate
and Rihanna have you found out what's on
there when we spot you obviously live on
your own right so how have you found it
yes sir it's been an interesting one but
yeah the isolating by myself working
from home only being able to communicate
with people sort of five video is sir
it's completely different and but it's
something that I think everyone's just
getting used to now it's sort of just
mean isn't it because we recruit into
the tech market is also an industry
that's still doing quite well throughout
this whole situation so I'm quite
fortunate in the way that I am still
recruiting for a lot of clients and
actually the majority well a big
proportion of what we'd normally recruit
for is reduced dramatically given the
circumstances and I think that's quite
normal across the board
so without Sonia to
it's just a really interesting
situations have to try and get your head
around and working remotely and trying
to motivate people motivate people
remotely but generally it's just been a
it's been a bit of a whirlwind last
couple of months to be honest because
you start of thinking yeah it's only
gonna be a couple of weeks yeah
definitely and now we're sort of eight
nine weeks II probably going to be
another couple of months so it's just
it's just a life we're gonna have to
adapt to you to be honest yeah
but yeah without some new general I
think everybody's probably in the same
boat cool now that's good just to set
the scene for everyone I guess so the
first question that I wanted to start
with I think this podcast is all about
creating a place where we can have open
honest conversations about the the
working in recruitment right so the
first question that really stood out to
me was from Sean Kennedy and it was
basically he basically asked what what's
been your toughest challenge as a leader
during this period and how have you
dealt with it let's just sort of start
there because I think right now a lot of
people may think that the challenges
they're facing they're facing them alone
but I know that a lot of people going
through what they're going through so
what what made me start be Rihanna what
have you found most difficult and how we
push through yeah the main challenge for
me sort of the first month of being
locked down and having to manage
remotely my team are quite inexperienced
so my most experienced person on my team
has only sort of six months in oh wow
didn't break very well but my other two
people in my team were sort of three
months and maybe a month after that so
sure it was it's very difficult to one
dedicate as much time as you need to
people that are relatively new to the
business I think time is the main issue
okay your fish you can quite literally
swing around to someone's desk and spend
two three minutes with them to show them
how to do something yeah still trying to
get people up to speed it was pretty
much half an hour to an hour
I'm screen sharing showing people how to
do things and it's it's just quite
time-consuming and I felt like I wasn't
dedicating enough time to people in sort
of their learning and development needs
to be honest that was my main challenge
but all the general things are trying to
keep people motivated ensuring that
people's mental health is still in sort
of a positive environment when they're
working remotely working from home don't
have a team around them so see you try
and keep people motivated and actually
just to say everybody's in this together
and there's no sort of right or remark
so at the moment but we just need to see
that you're doing as much as you can
yeah so that was probably that's
probably the main challenge but like I
said I miss my team a lot okay yes I'm
quite fortunate I suppose in some ways
that I'm now just being an individual
contributor but very much yeah so I
think just just fair runs context then
Rhianna yeah so furloughed your team as
you said so for so for what the last
what four weeks three weeks you've just
been focusing on billing and being an
individual contributor yeah
okay cool okay great to know and Charles
what about you what's been the biggest
challenge for you yes I mean I I mean on
so I moved into a management bidding
role quite a while ago now so about two
years really so for me it's kind of
first of all like when this all happened
obviously appreciate but no one really
knows how long this is all gonna go on
before things like that so we're I guess
the first thing I wanted to kind of do
was maybe when we all went no we're all
on lockdown was okay I really don't want
to kind of completely throw away all the
good stuff that makes us a good team
because of this like I want to try
obviously I appreciate there's going to
be a bit of change and things like that
but fundamentally like keep as much as
that as possible keep the collaboration
going keep the support keep the sharing
of ideas I guess like try try as our
hardest to kind of sort of keep keep
this a one-to-one coaching going and I
think you know we're also like
give me a lot down still still
interviewing for people and we were
still kind of in a position where we
were like yeah we're still gonna hire
because you know if we find good people
we we've always been like that you know
if they're good people
we'll make a space for them so I guess
so for to start with certainly for the
first sort of two three weeks was
probably actually like okay
oh my guys okay yeah kind of take in a
little bit back from the job and more
about the individual because one of the
things one of the challenges is that you
will individuals and we've all got very
different lives out there behind you
know our job I've got I'm quite
fortunate that you know my team are are
experienced I think my consultant as it
has been with this probably that a year
and a half now and then I've got seniors
and principals in those so it's more
about them as individuals and making
sure they're okay and I've got one is
got kids one is on a flat on the road
others have only just moved in with
their partners after never before which
you know that can be a big situation and
so I think like straightaway like people
first are you guys okay like checking in
doing all that is awesome and then I
think it kind of sort of then moved into
more like okay well like I said I don't
want this to be I don't want to be
different to how I am in the office sure
oh I'm not I'm not micromanaging I think
Carl's mentioned it in there in terms of
your difference between and like I
definitely want people to know one there
for them so it kind of turned into more
of like a strategic kind of slots
throughout the week yeah obviously
Rhianna you're talking about right
because you could just swing by their
chair but now it's like actually we've
got a book in the zoom call or something
like that so it's interesting that okay
it's how okay so you've then had to work
out yes specific times where you do
certain things and we've got dedicated
time yeah I think I think in people
people like that because they know it's
like okay cool well this is my time with
you to talk
start but also talk about work paint
getting on things like that I think we
also have to manage expectations all
around that sales are going to be down
we know that but okay if we're not doing
the deals then we need to make sure
we're doing everything we can to kind of
try and get us there
so actually where we would be
celebrating you know maybe wall around
sort of job activity you know the
interviews and always he deals maybe we
need to kind of scale that back in terms
of more around like okay cool wall who's
actually identified a company is hiring
right now that's actually a massive win
celebrate instable wins
yeah because ultimately we like
recruitment is is fed by confidence in
the market and right now confidence is
super low so people naturally go okay
cool well we were actually letting
people go we're probably not going to
bring anyone else in and you know it's
just kind of sort of light actually like
really celebrating when you find someone
that is hiring that scent all right well
we're definitely dive into that because
that there's quite a few questions
around and changing sort of the
goalposts talking about celebrating
small wins so far so we're definitely
dive into that and so I think only you
can hear us right yeah yeah we can we
can hear you fine mate so we're gonna go
yeah all these no stress so I guess for
you only what's been been some of the
biggest challenges for you mate over the
last couple of weeks yeah catching the
back of what real or and Charles are
saying is it really is a motivational
piece I think we're all really used to
working in a pretty vibrant offices
corks is really really important so
everybody and right we're honest and you
know going over to people's desk and
doing that bit big part of how we all
manage people and that for me has been
without doubt one of the hardest things
is you lose that connect in that side of
things so I think that's definitely the
toughest piece and then you know
everybody's running what are successful
hopefully successful recruitment teams
that people are used to winning and
doing well and kind of hitting hitting
their targets and the kind of thing and
I think you just need to adjust
expectations and Charles are saying okay
you start celebrating much smaller wins
you know work you know you stop move
away from celebrating yeah well you
celebrate more so I suppose when any
jobs on and things like that but really
start celebrating you know just getting
quality short list out where we can or
quality volume or just you know feeling
like you're chief something good in the
day just keeping positivity I think is
without doubt the hardest thing okay
awesome and look and only we can all
hear you okay right so don't don't
stress all good so I guess let's just
say go straight into this then it was
one of the questions I write down
charger touching and reality maybe this
is changed slightly for you when you've
had to structure your day on focus on
yourself and things like this but one of
the questions which was submitted by
Chris Bennett was pretty much around
this it was I'd really like to know what
team Daley selfs are ultimately how
you're now structuring your days you're
talking about the slots how how you're
sort of normal weeks now look how often
they speaking to their teams and using
what tech so Rihanna maybe you can start
maybe you obviously as you a segue and
your team's segue into furlough or
whatever but like how what does your
sort of normal day or week that like now
how do you structure their video
meetings when I did have my team what we
still doing now with the wider team that
I still work for me James is so be
honest is never gonna be a writer or
answer for this question yeah sure I
think people just want to know what of
how other people is structuring their
day and stuff like know doing individual
calls into my team in the morning see
wonders how they got on the previous day
and what their plans are for the day
essentially so before 9 o'clock it was a
coincidence I make sure that our bed as
well well then it was a nine o'clock
video meeting with the whole team yeah
and share like ideas what's working well
what's not working so well so it's
individual calls in the morning followed
straight after by a team video call and
then another team video call in the
afternoon session so we always have sort
of 5-10 minutes as a team twice a day so
in the morning in the afternoon and that
seemed to work really well and it was
actually something that we all looked
forward to as well and we sort of played
maybe some games in the video calls or
whatever it may be to keep us a bit of
positivity as well and not just keep it
all always the same yeah in terms of
communication and structuring my day it
was sweet sweet individual in the
morning and then to video cause 5-10
minutes every day and then of course it
was training sessions in between that if
anybody needed any assistance or support
hmm okay awesome thank you
I think one of the things that Charles
our she the same intersect but one of
the things that I've had recently with
one of my clients is that what he does
with his team is he'll and at the end of
the video catch that session what you do
he'll he'll get everyone to share like a
highlight of their day which i think is
a just a really cool and nice thing to
do as well which isn't just about work
and how many calls you made and all that
sort of stuff
Charles what what of your sort of days
weeks been looking like and how have you
structured it in terms of communicating
to your team and stuff of that yes I
think like like I said I've keen to kind
of make sure the you know we didn't
suddenly completely flip on our head
like what's actually brought us success
before so you know people talk about
like KPIs for instance and I think like
that's where for instance me as a
manager can maybe sort of review ok cool
where's an area that maybe we need to
kind of focus a bit more on as a team
and make it less about numbers are more
about outcomes and winds off that so and
that's kind of always been the mentality
I've never really kind of been a
stickler for the okay there's a number
of sales places nobody know things like
that I think it's a be more about okay
cool well if you're working really hard
and you're getting some really cool
outcomes and you know you can quantify
that and you can tell me about it then
I'm okay with that
I think obviously when you start working
remotely it's like okay cool well I
can't see it I can't feel it I have to
kind of sort of okay well how do i how
do I actually sort of monitor that or or
kind of make sure if someone is just
talking a good game and what it's kind
of a good night or think it's kind of
actually kind of sort of making it a bit
more competitive so yeah look you know
maybe it can be something around like
who can get the most CDs out and think
of that just actually more born out of a
bit of a pride thing because like I said
like fundamentally if we're not gonna be
doing deals then we need to kind of
demonstrate that we're doing all we can
to try and create those opportunities
and things like that and so just I guess
like being mindful of kind of you know
what kind of key activities we know that
bring success that we're we're aware of
and that we are keeping an eye on so
that people can help that sort of manage
their day we would never as a team like
had you know as many catch ups as
probably we are now so that's probably a
bit different however when G do yours
Charles and II do what we do now is like
in a Monday in the morning sorry every
morning it's an hour with all of us and
everyone brings to the table their their
biggest wins and real success is that
maybe like I said it's a company that's
hiring or its target part we've
identified new managers we've connected
with things like that and then it's like
I said a lot it's kind of catch ups with
the guys one-to-one throughout the week
because I was at interest I want it to
be like all the time like people need to
get on the out job like how long those
two catch that's typically Charles so
they're spaced out for up to an hour but
exactly they're driven very much by
their by the consultant so if they're
only 20 minutes then that's cool
yeah animal T because I've got some
principles from a consultant at senior
they're all at different levels where
okay I might be a little bit more around
nitty-gritty with the consult one level
where we're sort of looking into the you
know the information a bit more
actually like there and then live
offering guidance and things like that
just just looking at okay cool we're
going to get moving on identify
opportunities so let's make sure we're
maximizing every opportunity right now
we've got and that's where I can really
add value I think in that kind of
situation kind of stuck open cool like
that and then obviously la lost not Lisa
that Olli you want to add inference to
that how have you been
structuring communicating to your team
also you said sort of one biggest
challenges for you to be motivating your
team so how how many times are you
speaking to your team's on a daily or
weekly basis reasonably similar in that
we we have kind of a 9:00 a.m. set of
call every day and say 50% of that is
just a bit of a general chitchat and
having a bit of the last yeah I think
we're one of those things that you know
we'll get against the office pretty
early said I'm you know cup of tea
better breakfast another chit chat I've
always been quite keen to not lose that
yeah and keep that kind of cultural
peace going and then we'll have a
similar thing to you know kind of
towards the end of the day talk about
any successes talk about any challenges
any challenge anything that we need to
help with us oppose and then again they
just being constantly open to the
consult ones picking up the phone and
giving me a call if they need me so try
and sort of orange its over communicate
in that diffic
yeah exactly it's like not you know not
having like a zoom called books in
necessarily but like house just you know
if you need me just give me a call yeah
and then we've got a whatsapp group with
my team going constantly services little
things or little questions or you know
seen something helpful is sharing it
with the group and then let everybody
dive in with the answer as well so it's
not all coming from me it's coming from
you know with our solutions and I'm
pretty fortunate to have a really driven
team so the motivation piece kind of
comes from all of us
but yeah it's all digging deeper suppose
okay cool well hopefully that helped
some of you guys in terms of thinking
about how you're structuring and
communicating to your team so let
Charles you've obviously touched on it
quite a bit and I'd love to get Rihanna
and Holly your thoughts
and it was a question that came up quite
a lot so or quite T people sort of uh
pronounce this wrong and Z is their salt
and so if I pronounced that wrong but
basically that that question was any
changes in regards to goals or targets
you have set for your team for them to
keep feeling their succeed and to keep
them motivated and then and if so what
are those and then the question by
Louise Gilmore was given the current
market and hiring isn't actually slowed
down do you believe that concerns daily
targets should double in order to
achieve the same results we are used to
right so so I guess like you've been
talking about choice but maybe Rihanna
one of the things that came out to give
you some context one of the things that
came out of the a live podcast we did a
couple of weeks ago was one of the
managers changed and the sort of typical
Jettas of a number of sales calls new
business calls to clients and flip that
to focus on and cool times rather than
like really look at that so I guess
obviously making you feeling like you've
hit your targets or you've got something
to drive towards or C helps of the
motivation but what what have you saw
changed or different activities you've
looked at those that have helped with
that we just monitored more on managing
the controllables more than anything so
you can't really manage and you can't
really assess in advance how many
interviews you're going to arrange for
example because you don't know what the
markets going to be like or whether yeah
so fully and totally committed at the
moment and are prepared to interview or
whether they're just saying it so what
we sort of set is normal KPIs for the
week is something that we can control so
whether it's a certain amount of
messages that are going out to
prospective candidates awaiting with
candidates that are registered because
they are some things that you can't
control really at this stage in this
type of climate whereas like I said you
can't really control the revenue that
you yep moment or even a pipeline and
because you don't know at what point of
client is just gonna say actually no I
can't I can't do this maybe and I'm not
gonna be committed to taking
this candidate even to the point of
intimate in them so yeah we I mean we
changed our measurables based on
something that can be controllable so it
was the outreaches so how many people
you're going to prospect or contact a
week and how many candidates are you
gonna commit to sort of interviewing and
registering on our database per week
that was fair obviously if the
interviews follow oh great and if the
revenue and the deal was followed and
that's awesome but I think yeah based on
the manageable control the KPI is that
really no absolutely I know obviously a
lot of people give that advice control
the controllables but that it that
really just take some weight off your
shoulders when you really recognize that
and realize that I think that's a great
way to then filter into kpi's that's
completely right because and then you
can communicate to your team and other
people that they are in complete control
of reaching these and these outcomes so
really love that you put those two
together that that's awesome and only
what about you what sort of things have
you sort of maybe you had to change
there typically and would be you'd be
measuring them differently if the
circumstances were different and if in
to add to that yeah yeah it's quite
similar in that it's you want to measure
on things that people can control ya
know if you're looking at put in
incentives in its targets and it needs
to do something that consultants can
actually go out and achieve I think you
know the point where I'm kind of
doubling certain targets and stuffing is
it's the right thing to do in certain
areas but not in others you have you
know having all of a sudden got it's one
of you know it's one more time in your
day but yeah we absolutely need to be
chasing things harder and pushing harder
and driving harder but it needs to be in
the right places I think that's really
important I think that will continue as
well as you know we've all got KPIs and
targets set when we were back in the
office that were based on previous
results and previous delivery and I
think you know depending how long this
goes on for I think that would probably
become the case again where you go at
you know over the eight weeks so far
this is what people have been delivering
so that's what we're going to I'm going
to start basing targets on you know that
becomes the new that's a good thing
that's a bad thing that you know you hit
your target but things are still needs
to remain
foreseeable future around controllables
okay cool really like that Charles
anything to add may I know you've
already sort of touched on it but
anything to add that sort of helps you
manage your teams in terms of looking at
so I just think again like expectations
are right the goal is right now
cool people might not be hiring right
now clients that we know and love might
not be hiring right now however like use
this time more than ever when we have
done to build those relationships
because yeah nine times that said that's
where our business comes from actually
it doesn't come from : and things like
they does come from those relationships
and it's like use this as an opportunity
to build those relationships now so that
you know six-month time maybe when you
know this all this always behind it we
can you can capitalize on that you know
who you're calling and they're actually
going to know you now more than be like
how can you measure that though as a
manager how can you do not mean how
could I turn around to you and say
Charlie I've built so many good
relationships today okay yes again it
comes back to how you you organize your
database so I think most I would because
like we use bullhorn for instance like
all all consultants and their managers
part of the expectation is that they're
all organized in terms of where they sit
on ultimately a hierarchy of you know
potential sort of business development
so it already poking with them are they
people that maybe we've had jobs with
but not place with to ultimately target
clients that we're sent right okay cool
these are the people in the next three
to six months that we're going after we
know who they are we know the decision
maker and again like during your catch
ups you can quite quickly kind of look
at that as something okay so look at the
information yeah you know sometimes it's
like you know we get such good
information but then it's lost and we
forget where we put in things like that
and it's like this is such a good way of
like being like okay cool right where'd
you go to list of people that you know
back then told you that now is going to
be their times
okay like if you come out at the end of
this maybe you haven't done as many
deals as you would have done but you've
got a real slick database of like coins
that you know know you and you know when
they're gonna hire them that's that's a
massive win and that's a huge pipeline
so okay all right cool interesting I
guess just as we're on this before we
move on ask you the next question here
Marisa just put so yeah are you
targeting yourself maybe or your team on
on the buildings deals wise right now or
is it just strictly the things you can
control like do you I don't know do you
have monetary targets in place right now
ever any of you guys we still have those
targets in place okay it's important you
know we're all ultimately were all
revenue driven money driven individuals
or good hope so at least
I think people still need to have that
towards we've got in process and that
kind of thing I think you just need to
adjust that per consult and and you know
depending on what pipeline those go on
but yeah I think it's important still
the people have got a target around
revenue okay cool and if in to add
Rihanna or Charles or is it obviously do
you still have a monetary target in
place for your guys yes we still have
revenue targets as normal yeah okay cool
all right so just on on this topic and
obviously recruit recruiters the
industry a renowned for the incentives
right and these things typically involve
obviously a lot of drinking normally but
lunch clubs going to eat in nice places
holidays so quite a few questions that
come through and one from anger ads so
if I pronounced that wrong again but
basically the question was how are you
incentivizing your team's remotely
replacing things like lunch clubs etc so
what how would we found that and what
are you guys doing on that front Charles
maybe you could take that one first
like how are you incentivizing your team
so I'm
to be to be transparent around sort of
where we're at when when we'll see tough
decisions have to be made within the
business we have to look at realistic
expectations for what sales are going to
be like okay where we're we're probably
looking to kind of potentially that
might be 50% of where it where it should
be
and our CEO kind of quite quickly said
right okay fundamentally the biggest
thing for us is people first and looking
after as many people as we can so what
did that meant there was some
furloughing
they were based on the fact forest
things like that people are still gonna
be owning Commission and I think like I
think from our point of view things like
incentives obviously travel everything
like that it's basically like well
that's straightaway that's where they're
going to save to save people's jobs and
things like that so we have you know
into this kind of sort of realm I think
from from my point of view I mean there
was talk around we tried sort of maybe
like incentivizing people like
deliveries and things to be honest like
I think I'm really fortunate and I think
we are like the people that are with the
business now we're all we're all in it
for the long haul we get it like this is
this is we don't necessarily need
incentivize and beyond the fact that
look we get Commission if we do deal
still there are some companies out there
that aren't even paying their people
commissions so yeah you know I think you
know when it comes to how we manage our
people someone's very at the point there
about how do you deal with some of the
kids and things like that it's like with
be flexible with people you know we're
offering people so much like that you
know we want to help them through this
as well and be with us at the end of
this you know that's almost an incentive
in itself maybe that sounds cheesy but I
know you mean there's people in
seriously like tougher positions than
maybe we are so I just kind of feel like
with my guys it's like cool where the
where the chosen wants to get us through
this so we're all kind of you know bit
of Band of Brothers mentality maybe
something like that no
I love that I mean yeah delivery is
definite isn't the worst lie there but I
go you mean it's perspective it's look
guys that this is this is the journey
that we're on and yeah I mean hopefully
I'm sure the lunch club when we come
back it gets to normality beer
absolutely cracking won their first I'm
gonna get back so I guess and if it
sounds like Rihanna of you yeah I don't
know if there's only been some cooling
centers for across for near James that
might be quite cool to share or what you
guys been done Charles were saying to be
honest as it stands at the moment
there's a limited amount that we can do
and the fact that people still have
their jobs and there's still a
non-commissioned we're still in a market
where we are able to build sort of
revenue and get deals we're just
fortunate and I think not necessarily
from an incentive perspective but we're
still having like virtual quizzes with
the widest team economy I'm gonna put it
like yet they are yeah they are good we
will get to catch up with everyone
so it's not necessarily an incentive
it's definitely something that keeps
people entertained and a bit motivated
definitely from a social perspective
we've also started doing like virtual
yoga classes all times just not
something that I would have ever done
before but it's yeah it's really
enjoyable so yeah we getting everybody
involved in those types of things and
I'm sure it lunch clubs and stuff like
that they haven't even been mentioned
because I don't think people are even
thinking of yes you're there's nothing
that anyone can do so it's not someone
we can control but I mean there was a
trip this year to Mexico's and postponed
and what's New York in October that's
also may or may not going to be
postponed so it's just something that
everyone has to understand really at the
moment but yeah not necessarily from an
incentive perspective but definitely
from a motivational piece we were doing
quizzes we're doing yoga we don't know
about that we did try to do a virtual
career night but I think that one
yes sir things like that yeah now I
think I think it's that I mean I don't
know about you guys but like when you
sort of had maybe a couple of hours just
cracking on working on working by
yourself and then when you speak someone
if that's on a video call or call them
you just feel a bit more uplifted that
you just spoke to another human being
and just remember that you're not going
through this alone and and that really
does help and only anything to add made
before I'll see you guys another
question I don't know if you've you've
done anything or tried different things
that have helped with that on the
incentive I'd last eight weeks for us
has just been ultimately trading as hard
and we possibly can and was not really
happy incentivize people to do that I
think they they get kind of where the
business at and where the markets that
were in a good place if we want to keep
doing that you know we're going to have
to cut back on some of the bigger
expenses in the short term I think we're
now at that point as a management group
where we've started to look at you know
a plan for the rest of the year as to
how we bring incentives back and you
know they're obviously going to have to
be different to go into the pub for the
afternoon and stuff like that but it's
important that we have that there and
we're still rewarding success changes
what that reward is and probably what
that success is to get there as well
well yeah it's certainly something
that's on all of our minds to start
bringing that back in okay so it's
lonely let me give you this question and
to start with so quick I thought is a
really interesting one and it's a
question from Frank young which was um
it has that have you made a main change
to evil work or not work related that
has really helped you add that to the
current situation so that could
obviously be anything but I don't if you
just change anything in your sort of
weekly routine or daily routine that has
really helped you ver sort of personally
or just sort of professionally yeah I
mean my routines changed a huge amount
with without having to do a pretty bit
can you every day so I've got a lot more
time in my day I've tried to keep a bit
of routine there but so probably the
biggest thing I've tried to do is and
this is off the back of noting that was
far more productive in the morning than
I was in the afternoon so
try to structure my day quite
differently to make sure that I'm doing
you know maybe the more monotonous
things or the more difficult things in
the morning but all my calls and things
like that book in the afternoon for what
I ultimately know I probably will be
flagging a little bit and I need a
little bit of a pick-me-up so you know
I've tried it as many calls and I can in
the afternoon so that's what gives me a
bit of energy and gets me going a little
bit so that's probably kind of the
biggest change that I've made out of
thought yeah but I've tried to keep
everything as similar as I can you know
keep that routine tiyanak yeah now
that's really interesting
Rihanna what about you have you change
anything that has helped you join this
tip period a Pinterest commute also into
London from hop fishes so I've had a lot
more time in the in the mornings and the
evenings to be able to concentrate on
work but I suppose it's a difficult one
at the moment cause it's actually very
hard to switch off yeah whereas when
you're in the office it's very easy to
sort of get in set up start on time yeah
and then leave the office by sort of
5:45 6:00 6:30 whatever it is and by the
time you've sort of shut off your
computer and commute at home you are
sort of out of work really yeah may or
may not check your email I start the
evening but at the moment it's so easy
to find yourself my routines changed
because it's so easy to find myself
still on my laptop there yeah evening
still doing work or so I think that
that's also a challenge because it's
something that a lot of people will be
struggling with at the moment is you do
still have to give yourself that time in
the evening to just shut off you have to
work extra hard at the moment you should
just be I suppose working extra smart
but it's really difficult not to yeah
definitely I definitely spoke about this
didn't win I found that really difficult
if you'd ever done anything to try and
combat that then of you sort of start to
put your phone away at certain time or
I've started to do more things outside
of work so I'm cooking from scratch more
and I'm going
done those types of things before okay
I'm actually just enjoying the ID those
are the things that I'm doing I suppose
in my personal life to be able to help
me motivate myself a little bit more and
to be able to just separate work from
social yeah because like I said live by
myself and I'm always in my flat so it
is there's not that division where I'm
going from the office to home there's
that yeah tireless yeah yeah totally
yeah that's awesome like I haven't
really changed much to my day to be
honest I structure my day they're saying
my speak to the same clients I identify
the same candidates but of course it's
just a little bit more challenging to do
to the climate cool Charles last but not
least what I mean have you made any
changes they've helped you like what's
been going on in your world yes
obviously from from a work perspective
so obviously as I mentioned I was a non
building effectively manager but so was
due to have a new starter in July which
was a grata part of our graduate program
that starters was he to put back I think
to September so I kind of took the
decision that after probably about a
month of with the guys and working the
way we have been that probably there
comes a point where it's like okay I
feel like the guys have got lifts yeah
and my time looks at I'm not
interviewing anyone anymore
like the way I work with my boss is that
he he's like scaled down massively like
he's cut it up so I was like actually
I've got more time now which I can maybe
invest back to hopefully bring in some
revenue as well so I've ever dated sorry
got back on the phones yeah yeah yes
that's all I've started sort of looking
at the market that she's going to be
coming in to when she starts okay cool
so essentially the way I'm looking at is
the sooner I can kind of get back in a
really good State for her maybe in a
position where it's yielding some
results no maybe we bring it that's not
both forward for instance and things
like that there's a bit an incentive
there but definitely I think that the
switch off is a big thing I like to
think that on
always on call sort of thing but like
you have to make time for yourself like
whether it's the exercise or you know
just binging on Netflix just to kind of
just give your brain a bit of a you know
bit of distraction sort of think it's
really really important for everyone's
well-being so definitely I think I think
it's um it's I mean I'm particularly
obvious in recruitment and there's sort
of high standards we gave ourselves it's
it's easy to be higher than yourself
right and I think and that's what I've
done I'm really quite hard on myself and
sometimes you give yourself a bit of a
break and does that mean you can watch
target King all day not sure but you
know I mean you need you need yeah don't
be too hard on yourself
definitely so look guys what I'd love to
sort of get your your points on is let
you've all been in recruitment for a
good amount of time
Rihanna you said it Olli you said that
you normally obviously have a commute
and like what what does I think
obviously going into this period there
was way more talks and conversations on
flexibility in recruitment for day weeks
and obviously Rihanna you guys have
tried different things in the past to
look at this and maybe you have things
in place already Charles in terms of
flexible working but quite a few
questions come through just on what what
does sort of flexible working in
recruitment look like when we start
coming back out of this may be Rihanna
you could start because I think that's
going to be a really interesting thing
that evolves I start coming back out of
this so I guess obviously maybe no one
no one knows but be good just people's
when they're hear people's thoughts what
what do you think sort of flexible
working like that like in and
recruitment as we sort of start coming
back out of this I mean we were quite
fortunate and Jonas our I've always
supported a working from home policy
anyway so we have always had that
flexibility and I think it will be more
so the individuals people will make up
their own mind as to whether they can
work efficiently from home or whether
they are better off in the office so we
will still offer that flexibility of
working from home but people may or may
not choose sir so I suppose do it
because a lot of people are more
efficient
in the office so I don't know what will
change for us but I suppose
industry-wide it will be interested to
see companies that didn't think they
could support a worker from home I'd be
interested to hear what other companies
do after this because you don't think
you can have the infrastructure you
don't think you can have the setup at
home but it's proven that businesses
that didn't ever do that and if I didn't
have that they would have been forced to
do it now right yeah I don't know change
for us I'm not too sure when we
anticipate being back in the office but
ultimately it will be interesting to see
how people how efficiently people are
working from home and whether that
continues but ultimately we've always
had a working from home policy so it's
just you haven't you haven't gone back
an office yet and started moving chairs
to the each side of the office and put
stickers on the floor and stuff of that
done that yet may be happening in
Manchester London at the moment because
of commuting and the tubes and staffs it
may be a little bit longer than we
anticipate but I did have an anxiety
moment the other day thinking that I may
have left like an apple or an eyeliner
in my desk yes
but I don't know when I don't know what
the situation is going to be to assess
but we've always worked from home anyway
so cool okay
only what about you buddy what and
cousin that was he Ivan had joke latest
on the podcast and when I've been to
your office it's really good vibrant
energy and that's a big part of what you
guys have over there so what are your
thoughts on as you start coming back how
this flexible working and what that
might look like it's really interesting
what I think it's always been a massive
sell point for us as a business in terms
of retaining staff and also bringing
kind of new consultants into the
business is social aspect of it and it's
a massive bit for people that still work
there so yeah I do think they'll be
probably a bit more of a shift to
flexible I suppose the flexible side of
things but I don't think we'd ever
really want to put something in this
superstructure and I'm not sure
a recruitment perspective how that would
work you know if I had every Friday
offer clients there kind of meet you on
Friday I know I want to be in meet them
so yeah it's you know in such a
face-to-face industry I think you have
to have that flexibility and that's
where it you know you then take that
balance of is it work-life balance and
you do a few days a week from home but
you change which days they are or
whatever it is I think that has to be
considered and then you know that the
guys have sent around more junior staff
coming in as a team manager how do you
get them want to meet on what
recruitment is how it works and all of
that kind of stuff but also a proper
part of the team and part of the
business I think that's again is quite
hard to move working flex remotely
because a huge apart thing that will
have people in because your huge partner
Leon is a huge part ideal not only is
that and also if you guys agree is that
yeah being around successful recruiters
experienced recruiters you can learn
from right and you can soak up here and
how Rihanna's talking on the phone I you
know I only use that part and all that
and that that that can be that's going
to be really difficult to replicate that
remotely isn't that I think that that's
a really interesting point particular in
the sort of junior coming into
recruitment level Charles as you as you
quite state at the beginning you've been
in recruitment for a while what will be
you think and mate what anything they'll
adore I think I think for me personally
like I know that there's a there's a
hell of a lot of loyalty that is bred
from having a team that are with each
other
May and day out and things like that and
I think it's really really important for
a business that you know that they they
still maintain that loyalty because
that's something that I think could
potentially get lost quite quickly like
I've seen a lot of recruiters that have
gone to companies purely on their remote
working policies because they're like
are that's the dream right and it's like
okay but actually they've they've hopped
a bit and they've gone on to other
places and I kind of you know of any
other boomer doston Fraser so if my
mentality is a bit like you know is that
a bit of a lack of loyalty there as a
result of it do you really buy into the
culture if you're not
in a part of it all the time and things
like that I basically the way I am with
with my guys and where we are as a
business here is it if you need it I
have it but but also there's you know I
want people that also want to be in
amongst it as well yeah you're one of
those people that's like I and even want
to be remote then you probably not right
for my team anyway okay but it's just
not not how we're personally I feel I
get the best results out of people I
want I want people before in I want
people to see what they're all a part of
and but I definitely want people you
know who have different lives outside of
recruitment to still be able to have
that right work-life balance so what we
want to work and take time they need it
and ultimately as long as without start
coming in and you know we're not seeing
like meet the major issues from a
development piece then there's
definitely something that we can do for
that that's not okay cool I'm eight so
look fine um final question guys unless
some other people some any questions if
you want so you really want a question
answered submit in the Q&A and we'll
make sure we get it answered but just I
think a really good question to finish
on so Charles I'll come to you first and
so there's a question by Joe and Bunge
and what he asked was when you when you
look back at the look down in six months
time what will you be most proud of
having achieved and most regretful of
having let fall to the wayside okay okay
so think about what my home site will be
in the future yes we will add that right
I think what I'm generally what I'm most
proud of is the fact that you know we
talked about it earlier with incentives
and things like that is that like you
know what like my team I'm gonna be feel
like they're there in it to win it they
really want to they want to help us all
get through this and I think the
mentality that I've seen from so many
individuals in the business about like
you know coming up with new ideas of
like a company helped a client or maybe
something that's a bit gray air
to kind of help them now so that in the
future their work with us on the more
core market stuff and things like that
you know all these cool ideas that are
coming out I think that's probably been
it one of the one of the the best things
I've seen look you really know who's
who's up for it sort of thing now and I
think I think like probably some of the
some of the mistakes or sort of the the
things I've not been too keen on was
maybe there was a bit of a maybe a
knee-jerk reaction for maybe some of the
the social sort of posting sort of thing
I think it was almost like too much
noise
that okay I mean within that there was
probably a lot of good stuff but it got
lost amongst quite a lot of drivel that
was getting thrown out there as well and
and I kind of like I felt like people
that were sort of having some really
good things to say were probably
probably lost in a monk's of everyone
jump in on this kind of got to get stuff
out they've got a got a little busy
couldn't really good a do on the content
front sharing content they're just
content that was going out there and
things like that and I think might
sometimes there was some really good
stuff but also there was some really
sort of questionable stuff that I was a
bit like okay and I think like we kind
of were kind of sort of streamlined it a
bit better now that it's it's hitting
all the right sort of areas that we want
it to hit and I think that's probably
probably where it's at and not not
panicking that okay we're going to
change everything now because of this
like let's think about what the good
stuff is and maintain that okay cool I
know it's a ton it's difficult question
but that's one is that ask it we are
most proud and hopefully when you look
before yeah most proud than maybe the
thing that you may think you may let
slip I think from an individual
contributor perspective I think the
thing that I'm gonna be able to look
back and be proud on is actually still
managing client relationships and still
building revenue
I think everybody expected to have a
pretty low couple of months during this
time in terms of what they're gonna bill
winter reven
you and we are fortunate that we've
we've got some really cool clients that
are still hiring at the moment so I
think I think ultimately you've just got
to take anything that could have been
seen as a normality before whereas now
actually is a added bonus that companies
are still hiring and we are still placed
in candidates into roles so yeah billing
still basically yeah something I'm gonna
look back and be proud of and also just
being able to keep myself motivated and
and as a business we have just been very
supportive if people's individual
circumstances we've given the option for
people to go on furlough it wasn't
forced upon anybody and so it was more
so if you want to have some time out you
are allowed it and I think we're gonna
be able to look back on and say we did
actually support a lot of people
throughout this time the thing is I'm
gonna look back and wish I do
differently I'm not too sure to be
honest yeah yeah as a hard one for me
especially gonna be naughty as much I
think
[Music]
but look and last not least Olli I guess
let's just keep it with looking hoping
to come back soon one time what are you
gonna be much proud of orally hopefully
yeah I think they're kind of a big thing
to me just like keeping the keeping the
team going and everybody's getting
better at every single day and I think
that's the big thing that I think in six
or five of us are however far in the
future I think all of us will probably
come out of this as a better recruiter
having been through it yeah and I'm
having to have more difficult
conversations having to push more than
work to reassure candidates and do all
of that bit that piece and I think it
takes throughout that complacency and
having done recruitment for seven years
and puts you right back at the start
again I think I'm also more thorough
recruits that having done that and then
ultimately yeah how the buying of people
is well done you know how well the guys
research of managed the business to get
us to where we are now
Kieffer's going and they're putting a
plan in place and that side I think you
know you can look everybody should look
back at this and see how they've handled
it and take it as a real science of
things moving forward as well yeah now
that's that's all some of it very well
put and well look that is that has the
lot of podcast guys go there in the end
and then we had a few technical issues
or leave thanks our darling inmate we
heard you loud and clear added some
really great points it's okay and well I
just wanted to say big thanks to Charles
Rianna Orly really appreciate you coming
on being really open honest shared
hoping getting on with things shared
your challenges and I hope everyone that
joined us today thank you firstly and I
hope you will enjoy their core value
from it and yeah we're definitely be
doing this again over the next couple of
weeks so keep your eyes out for that but
just a big thank you guys and